what we were asking was
the peace process negotiations
should move in tandem with the
withdrawal
so that there is no
sense of insecurity anxiety
we've been saying consistently pakistan
i've been saying in my engagements
withdrawal is inevitable
make sure
that it is a
responsible and orderly withdrawal and
what we saw on the tv it was not
responsible and not orderly
you see why was it such a rush the
international community has to
wear the options
one option is engagement
as opposed to isolation
you know we've withdrawn
let's wash our hands we've done our bit
you know we leave
that's a dangerous option
there's an option of abandonment of
afghan people
of people i'm talking of the people
that's the mistake that was committed in
the 90s
i would urge
the international community not to
repeat the same mistake again and what
will happen if that mistake is repeated
there will be there will be uh
could lead to a civil war
things could uh become chaotic there
could be anarchy
and that will give
space
to the organizations
that we all dread
the international terrorist organization
that we do not want their footprint to
grow in afghanistan it sounds to me as
though you are urging western powers to
recognize
the taliban as the legitimate rulers of
afghanistan no no
i'm not doing that i am saying
engage
why am i saying engage i'm thinking
engage because the disengagement
the consequences of disengagement are
far worse
now
look at the initial statements that the
taliban have made
uh
they're positive
they're encouraging the international
community is not sure
whether they mean them
will they implement
these pronouncements
or is it just a tactic
test
test
we do kind of know what the taliban is
like because we saw what they did
between 1996 and 2001
there is a catalogue of human rights
abuses
you talk about
the taliban this new taliban making
positive
signs and saying positive things
do you believe do you believe
they've changed and do you believe they
can be trusted
all i can say is i hope they have
i hope they've learned from their
mistakes
they've suffered as well
they've been isolated uh
you should feel sympathy for the taliban
is that what you're saying no no
they should learn
they should have learned from their
mistakes
and i think the the attitude and the
approach that they are demonstrating so
far
is reflective of a different approach so
you think they have changed you think
they can be trusted at this moment in
time
i i what i'm saying is
test them
test them
before trusting them
they've made statements
let's see if they live up to them
and if they do
then build on it
because
the other option is far worse
if they are sensible
if they are sensible
they should in my view respect
international opinion and international
norms why
they need assistance
they will be in charge if they will be
in charge
they will need humanitarian assistance
they will need financial assistance
otherwise you will see an economic
collapse and do we want to see an
economic collapse and if there is an
economic collapse look at the
repercussions look at the consequences
that would lead to in certain parts of
pakistan the taliban flag was raised
when the americans announced the
withdrawal people cheered in the streets
there's also an accusation in many
western
capitals that pakistan
sponsored the taliban
provided strategy for the taliban
allowed them to cross
the border
there are some who are saying that
actually in islamabad
the government here is quite pleased
that the taliban have won what would you
say to those people
first of all if there was a raising of
flags and jubilation
do not forget
that there are over
4 million afghans living in pakistan
many
have
connections with taliban they're related
their families
they have been living here
for almost now
four decades
they want to go back home
and the prospect so that's what the
celebrations are about the prospect of
returning home
uh
obviously you know gives you
some
sense of relief and what about the
accusation pakistan was playing a double
game is the truth in that
you see that that's nothing new you know
one has been hearing this for for years
now
is it true
pakistan sincerely
cooperated with the international
community pakistan sincerely
wanted peace uh and stability why did it
cooperate with the taliban too
talapan did not require
our cooperation you see what people
forget that people were sent from here
they were already there
all the militants
were in afghanistan
the political leadership was sitting in
doha negotiating the fighters were in
afghanistan even before the withdrawal
40 to 45 percent of the territory was
under their control
they didn't need our nord consent or
help
you know they were managing their own
affairs